you know I want to say one thing here at
the at the top and I was thinking about
this yesterday as I was out checking my
hive I think I think one of the great
marketing decisions of all time maybe
the greatest really was to call it honey
rather than be vomit which is basically
what it really is when you put honey
like on your toast or whatever you are
you are smearing bee puke all over a
piece of bread let's be honest but well
I'm not technically puke I mean the bee
does store the nectar in a stomach
that's separate from the one used for
digestion but at the end of the day
you're eating something that thousands
of bees regurgitated that's I mean
that's just what's happening and in fact
actually they they regurgitate it into
the two combs right and the combs are
made from wax which is secreted out of
the bees pores like a sort of gelatinous
sweat and then what happens is that is
the the bee vomit is scooped out of the
bee goop and put into bottles and then
you put it in your tea you freak what is
wrong with you anyway just just a just a
thought speaking though of actually I
could do a transition here speaking of
rebranding attempts the left is
celebrating today what CNN describes as
boundary breaking Muslim supermodel
Halima Aydin who has made history once
again they say by becoming the first
model to wear a hijab and burqini in the
Sports Illustrated Swimsuit Issue now
here's a picture of her there it is and
that's a so-called bikini which is a
combination of a burka and a bikini
really it's just a wetsuit it's like
something that somebody would wear you
know the scuba diving or something but
this is supposed to be some kind of
great moment of cultural diversity and
as I said the left and feminists are
very excited about it
so I have a few things to say here first
of all combining a burka and a bikini
makes about as much sense as putting an
ice coffee
the microwave it's these are opposites
they are doing two opposite things you
can't really you can't really combine
them the whole point of a burka is
extreme sexual modesty that's the entire
point of it and the point of a bikini is
sort of the opposite of that so to wear
a garment that is meant for sexual
modesty while striking a pose and
rolling around in the sand so that your
picture can be taken and put in a
magazine alongside a bunch of barely
clothed supermodels
well that that really makes no sense at
all more to the point though I certainly
believe that Muslim women should be
allowed to wear what they want I'm a
die-hard supporter of religious liberty
for all people but it requires an
extraordinary amount of cognitive
dissonance for feminists in America to
celebrate burkas and his abs hijabs I
don't probably pronounce adentro he jabs
his abs another one anyway
you know it's it's one thing to say yes
women have the right to wear those
things well of course they do
and nobody disputes that at least nobody
in America disputes that but to
celebrate it as feminists tend to do in
America is absurd women in Muslim
countries are required to wear these
things
according to societal standards of
extreme sexual modesty in some countries
they can be imprisoned or killed for not
wearing them the idea behind it is that
only a woman's husband is allowed to see
her entire head basically so this is
about enforced modesty and it's about
the authority that a husband has over
his wife and that more generally
speaking that men have over women
there's a reason why women are supposed
to wear the burkas and stuff not men
because men can show their hair and they
can have their whole heads visible but
women can't because the woman is the
property of the man
just to just to put this into context
the websites Islam question-and-answer
so a website you can go check out which
provides answers about Islam and this
website provides proudly some quotations
from the hadith in the Quran about the
hijab and about why women are supposed
to wear it so here's one here's one
quotation that's provided it says and
tell the believing women to lower their
gaze and protect their private parts and
not to show off their adornment except
only that which is apparent like both
eyes for necessity to see the way or
outer palms of hands or one eye or dress
like veil gloves head cover apron and to
draw their veils all over their bodies
and not to reveal their adornment except
to their husbands or their fathers or
their husbands fathers or their sons or
their husbands sons or their brothers or
their brothers sons or their sisters
sons or their went Muslim women or the
female slaves whom their right hands
possess or old male servants who lack
vigor or small children who have no
sense of feminine sex and let them not
stamp their feet so as to reveal what
they hide of their adornment and all of
you beg Allah to forgive you all o
believers that you may be successful ok
so this is I mean this is The Handmaid's
Tale but in real life this is women are
they can show it to the men in their
life they can show their hair and their
full head at the very least but not
beyond that so that it is not tempting
to - you know men out in public you know
feminists are running around claiming
that The Handmaid's Tale is about to be
a reality in America because Mike Pence
is vice president meanwhile Handmaid's
Tale actually is a reality in places
like Saudi Arabia and Pakistan and they
say nothing about it in fact let me show
you this look at this graphic here
people were pulled by
ooh research people were pulled by Pew
say that five times fast in a variety of
Muslim countries as you see there is
Tunisia Egypt Turkey Iraq Lebanon
Pakistan Saudi Arabia and they were
asked how a woman should dress and as
you can see from the responses sizable
majorities in these countries thought
that at most a woman should show her no
Zayed eyes and mouth that's that's the
motion should be able to show nothing
else no hair even not even like the chin
and in places like Saudi Arabia most
thought that women shouldn't show
anything but their eyes these
respondents were also asked if women
should be a lot should be allowed to
wear something else if they want like
should they be allowed to choose or
should they be forced to wear these
these these things and forty to fifty
percent in these countries said no they
should not be allowed to choose they
should not be allowed to choose their
own outfits they should be forced
legally to wear the hijab or the burqa
and feminists say nothing about this
worse than nothing they celebrate this
clothing item which is a symbol of
exactly the sort of oppression and
suppression and persecution that they
pretend to be fighting against in this
country now as I said I have no problem
with religious modesty I'm I don't have
a problem with that
I think obviously when you when you when
you get to the point where women are
essentially walking around in body bags
or burlap sacks basically that is
extreme that is that is that is
oppression there there is a distinction
between modesty and oppression and
that's oppression but the greater
problem here is first of all the
prevailing attitude in many Muslim
countries is that this modesty should be
obligatory with rather harsh penalties
up to and including death now even for
the most extreme forms like wear only
the I use is shown if a woman in this
country wanted to walk around like that
then you
I respect that choice because it's not
forced but the problem is in many Muslim
countries it is either forced by law or
by societal custom now you'll see that
there are apologists who will say oh now
you'll pull up a Wikipedia article or
something I was like no I mean in Muslim
countries women can wear what they want
most of these countries you know it's
only the most extreme and conservative
like Saudi Arabia where they're required
by law to wear this stuff but you know
legally they went yeah that might be the
case legally in fact I think even in
like Afghanistan technically legally a
woman can basically wear what she wants
but she can't really because the
societal pressure means that she has to
wear the the burka and if she doesn't
she could she puts her life in jeopardy
so that's that's the problem also the
point is at the left certainly does have
a problem with religious modesty most of
the time except where it pertains to
Muslims you know you don't see them
celebrating conservative Christian women
who wear you know the long skirts that
go down to the ankles you don't see them
celebrating nuns in what nuns wear you
don't see them celebrating the modesty
of Orthodox Jewish women in fact in all
of those cases feminists will mock and
sneer and and and point to that as an
example of why you know Christianity is
is sexually repressive and repressed and
all of that but with Muslims suddenly
it's a cause for celebration the
hypocrisy is extraordinary truly it
really is and this is why American
feminists are some of the most
fraudulent cowards you will ever
encounter if feminism in America I've
said it a million times I'll say it a
million more times if feminism in
America is totally worthless it is a
worthless hypocritical coward
the pageant basically and nothing more
than that because if these if feminists
feminism meant anything if these
feminists really cared about women's
rights they would be focusing almost all
of their energy on what's happening to
women in Muslim countries because in
America women can wear what they want
they can do what they want they can say
what they want they have all the same
rights as men in fact they have they
have rights that men don't have they
have more rights than men arguably not
even arguably the right to kill your
child is a right possessed only by women
not by men so if they actually cared
about women's rights they would say oh
look well we succeeded in America
mission accomplished
good for us let's go focus on Saudi
Arabia and Pakistan and Afghanistan but
they don't not only do they ignore that
but they celebrate the persecution of
women over there hypocritical cowards
all of them all right I wanted to
mention this Beth Moore is a prominent
evangelical I suppose a Christian leader
is what she's considered anyway and she
sent out a tweet yesterday that's worth
discussing for a moment here's the tweet
it says there are simply no gospel
grounds for defending white supremacy
none this isn't theological rocket
science the savior of the world gave
himself on the cross for our sins to
live to deliver us from the present evil
age according to the will of our God and
Father wearing a brown body now actually
putting aside the phrase they're wearing
a body that you know that has a little
bit of a vaguely heretical sound to it
but
putting that aside obviously I agree
okay you agree we all agree and that's
the point that we all agree this is
another example of paper tiger
Christianity this is a Christian taking
a stand that's supposed to seem bold and
brave and necessary but actually is safe
and obvious and certain to provoke no
disagreement whatsoever from anyone now
notice how she phrases this she says
there are simply no gospel grounds for
defending white supremacy none period as
if she's arguing with someone but who is
she arguing with who is making a Gospel
argument for white supremacy who has
anyone done that now there are some
white supremacist out there that we know
and those people are evil freaks all of
them but they are a very small minority
and they are condemned by almost
everyone else and I've never heard even
anyone in their camp make a gospel based
argument these evil sociopaths who shoot
up synagogues maybe in their manifestos
they might say something about Jesus I
don't know maybe that I don't read the
manifesto so I don't really know what
they say because I don't I don't care
what they have to say or what their
opinions are but I'm pretty sure I could
be wrong I'm pretty sure that these
freaks are not offering theological
arguments for mass shootings these these
manifestos are not theological
dissertations right so even in the
community of people who actually believe
in white supremacy the argument is not a
theological one so what Beth Moore is
doing here is twofold number one she's
pretending to be bold and brave and
courageous by tape by staking out a
position that 99% of everyone agrees
with number two more insidiously she's
implying she is strongly implying that
there is a sizable percentage of
Christians who do think that the Bible
supports white supremacy she an
evangelical Christian a you know
supposed Christian leader he is making a
strawman of Christianity and painting
Christians as white supremacist
and she's doing it all to make herself
look better by comparison that's the
game here this is not just about someone
virtue signaling by taking on an easy
subject and pretending that it's
difficult it is that too and there's way
too much of that going on in
Christianity America these days but it's
also as I said a straw man it's it's the
kind of thing you expect an atheist to
say ranting against Christians who use
the Bible to justify racism even though
almost no Christian is really doing that
so if you're gonna get up there say
whether there is no biblical argument
for XYZ then you should be able to
provide examples of people especially
prominent people who are trying to make
a biblical argument for X Y Z and if you
can't provide any examples at all then
the question is why are you even saying
that what's the point of making that
it's like if I got up there and said I
don't know is it there is no gospel
argument for robbing liquor stores there
is no gospel argument for armed robbery
none Jesus condemns it now that's true
of course but if I'm gonna say that then
I think it's it is logical for you to
respond and say who's making that
argument is anybody and if nobody is
making it then why am I even saying this
we all agree what's the point of it well
there is a point and as I just explained
and I think the point is actually
shameful all right this is this is
important
watch Bette O'Rourke he was on MSNBC
last night and he hears here this is
very important you need to see this
watch let me let me just sharpen this a
little bit though cuz I think this sort
of gets to kind of the nub of the issue
right I mean we haven't done this yet we
have been standing idly by while we've
been omitting more and more carbon in
the atmosphere we've made it harder we
now have to undertake some kind of crash
program
and I guess my question to you is do you
see the oil and gas industry as an
opponent in that won't you have to fight
them won't you have to declare yourself
in opposition to their interests well I
think the short answer is yes in in some
significant way we know that certain oil
and gas corporations have been fighting
public policy on this issue have been
hiding their own science and in research
at the expense of our climate and and
human life so so wherever those two
things come in contrast or in opposition
I'm always going to choose the people of
this country having said that I want to
make sure that those who work in the oil
and gas industry those who work in the
fossil fuel industry are brought along
as partners to make sure that we make
this transition in the 10 years that we
have left to us as the science and
scientists tell us to make the kind of
bold change that we need we cannot
afford to alienate a significant part of
this country and we cannot do this by
half measure or by only half of us it
can't be Democrats versus Republicans
big cities versus small towns we all
have a shared interest in a cleaner
future for this country so I'm gonna
work with listen to everyone anytime
anywhere to make sure that we advance
this agenda and get to zero net net zero
greenhouse gas emissions by 2050 did you
catch that ten years it's ten years now
Beto says that we have 10 years left to
live it was 12 yet we had 12 years old
six okay so Alexandria Kaiser Cortez
said like six months ago that we had 12
years and now we have 10 years left to
live so we lost two years in six months
so by that rate really we have what I
mean by that rate we're all gonna be
we're gonna be dead probably if I you
know in three or four years yeah you
know but still I mean 10 years is as
long as we have a few years left I guess
is the point we have time to eat drink
and be merry
and I mean what if we're all gonna die
anyway so it's what I don't get so I
don't get it if you're saying we're all
gonna die anyway then what's the point
of it sounds like we can't salvage it
the earth is doomed any effort we make
now to prevent it will be futile and so
let's just not worry about it
in fact I mean why even have an election
in 2012 no more elections no more
government or you know or presidents or
anything and well you know we'll have
ten years of anarchy well we just kind
of party and live it up and and then we
all die all right finally before emails
I wanted to get back into a subject that
we discussed yesterday kind of a follow
up clearing up two items related to the
subject we talked about we talked
yesterday about Trump's comments
pertaining to robert e lee Trump called
Robert Elia great general and then the
left freaked out and I said yesterday
that Trump was absolutely right
Lee was in fact a great general and
there's nothing wrong with pointing that
out I also said that we have to
understand Lee and the other Confederate
generals and Confederate soldiers in the
context of their time we have to
understand them within their own context
we can't judge them by modern standards
which isn't to say that we have to see
slavery as being okay obviously it isn't
it wasn't it never was never will be but
we can't expect people in history to
have the exact same perspective that we
have today now there were two general
responses to my arguments that I want to
address quickly one is that slavery
aside the Confederates were traitors and
we shouldn't honor traitors or respect
them and then the other is that it's
morally relativistic to say that we have
to judge people by the standards of
their time that's moral relativism
that's the argument so I'll answer both
those arguments as for the first that
the Confederates were traitors I would
say this you can disagree with the
reason why they seceded I do you know
there's no question that slavery
was a large factor in the secession
now slavery was largely the reason for
secession it was not the reason for the
war and that's the distinction that
people seemed to miss that's that's
that's the nuance here the war on the
from the North's perspective the war was
a war to preserve the Union it was not a
war to abolish slavery that was a
political you know kind of recasting of
the war that happened midway through
with the Emancipation Proclamation
Lincoln did that it was a brilliant
political move and he did that for
several reasons one of them was to was
to ensure that Europe did not intervene
on the side of the South because once he
could recast this as oh we're trying to
liberate the slaves then you're then the
Europeans who had already abolished
slavery we're not gonna want to get
involved to defend slavery but in it to
begin with that's not what the war was
about it was not about abolishing
slavery it was about preserving the
Union and for the south it was not about
protecting slavery at least for the
people that were doing the fighting it
was about defending their home and
achieving independence but so the causes
of the war for the reasons for the war
and the causes of secession are not
exactly the same these are really two
different things but as for secession
yes it is certainly valid to say that
they seceded for bad reasons fine but
putting aside the reason for a moment it
seems that people are arguing that
regardless of the reason to secede is to
be a traitor and and that I think is not
true or if it is true then the word
traitor is this is not necessarily
always a bad word because the
Confederates they were not trying to
overthrow the government they were not
trying to take over the country they
were trying to break away from the
country they were they wanted to take
their own land in their own States and
do their own thing which is not the same
thing as trying to overthrow a
government which is usually what civil
wars are about and that's why many
people argue that the civil war was not
really a civil war at all that we should
call it the war but
in the States because a civil war is
usually a war where two sides are
fighting for control of a central
government that's not what the Civil War
was you had one side trying to get away
from the central government and and you
know start their own their own
government the point is that secession
when you when you think of it that way
and again you put aside the reasons but
you just talk about what secession
itself secession is exactly what the
colonists did they said they wanted to
take their land and their colonies and
they wanted to do their own thing they
weren't trying to overthrow the king
they they weren't doing that they wanted
to just do their own thing and have
their own country and if they had failed
then George Washington and Thomas
Jefferson and those guys they would have
been hung as traitors and that's how we
would remember them today probably but
it's it's a similar thing and that
similarity was not lost on people at the
time this is one of the arguments that
southerners southerners made they said
well we're just doing what what the
founders did originally we're doing what
people did that's how this country was
this country is based on secession and
it is this country is literally founded
on secession that's what the colonists
did and that comparison was also not
lost on the British at the time you know
they they saw it and they saw it as
basically the same kind of thing and you
could say well again the colonists had
good reasons and southerners had bad
reasons yeah okay fine
but we're talking about what secession
is and in fact you know it's I think the
colonists did have good reasons for
secession or rebellion but that's not
quite as obvious or straightforward as
we tend to think it is there isn't you
could make an argument that the American
Revolution was not necessarily justified
now I'm not making that argument I think
it was but it's when you
sit down and study the history and the
surrounding circumstances it's not quite
it's a little bit more complex than we
tend to think and you know just like the
American Civil War there were many
reasons that led up to it but with the
American Revolution one of the primary
reasons was taxation and but one of the
reasons why the king was trying to
extract taxes from the colonies was to
pay for the defense of the colonies
which is not unreasonable right anyway
the point is that's a little bit more of
a complex moral subject than I think we
we sometimes make it out to be but
either way if we are saying that well
you're not allowed to secede and to
secede is to be a traitor well then what
does that say about George Washington so
I think your the argument is not about
well they're they're traitors because
they seceded the argument is about the
reasons for it right now as for the
charge that I'm a moral relativist
because I advocate judging people by the
standards of their time well here's the
distinction there we judge right and
wrong objectively but we assess moral
culpability in the light of historical
context so for instance a person who
held slaves and let's say the year 1400
when slavery was an accepted institution
everywhere in the world that person is
probably less morally culpable than you
would be today for the same action now
the action itself is just as wrong
slavery was just as wrong in the year
1400 as it is today in 2019 but the
moral culpability the personal
culpability of a person who engaged in
that practice five hundred years ago he
is going to be much more mitigated than
it would be for us today another way of
putting this is that there are certain
moral insights that seem obvious to us
today but were not obvious to our
ancestors and we have no right to feel
superior to them because we didn't earn
these insights we just were born into
them it's part of our culture
but it was not always a part of the
culture I mentioned yesterday that
Lincoln was in a vowed racist he said
that in 1858 in his in his debate with
Stephen Douglas he said that he doesn't
believe that black people and white
people are equal he doesn't support
their equality he thinks that the
superior position of the white race
should always be maintained legally
that's what he said now clearly if a
politician said that today he would be
run out of office and rightly so and he
would be a disgrace he would be shunned
he would be he would go down in history
as a as a racist scumbag and nothing
more but Lincoln said that in 1858 and
we tend to you know kind of overlook it
and and and look at the you know the the
overall context and and we try to at
least with him we look at it in
perspective as well we should because
the idea that all people across the
world are equal in Worth and dignity and
that even people who look completely
different from you are still entirely
human just like you are that idea was
not apparent to the vast majority of
people everywhere in the world for the
for for most of human civilization it's
apparent to us which is good but it was
not apparent to our ancestors and not
just our white ancestors but our
ancestors everywhere in the world I mean
in in in certainly in the in the you
know let's say the going back to the
1400s anywhere in the world you went to
you wouldn't you would encounter racism
and tribalism everywhere in the world
among all races it's just how people
operated back then it was still wrong
but the point is that it was a it was
just taken for granted and the idea
that all people are equal that is an
insight that developed slowly over time
and only very very very recently has it
become kind of mainstream and even then
only in certain countries there are
still plenty of countries where it's not
so we can either choose to condemn
almost all of our ancestors of all races
as barbaric scumbags or we can try to
see them in the context of their times
and afford them that grace and that you
know that's a perspective and I think we
have if we're going to study history
then that we have to have we have to
have that perspective we have to afford
them that grace I know that there are
actually plenty of people in America
today who would have no problem saying
yeah you know what they all love our
ancestors all of our a bunch of barbaric
scumbags all of them they're a bunch of
worthless you know animals there are
people that have that that would say
that and those are almost all people who
don't study history have not studied it
because when you have nothing but
contempt for people of history then
you're probably not going to be inclined
to study history and if you do study it
your your your vantage point is going to
be so skewed and so biased that you're
not going to be able to learn anything
so you have to be able to take off the
modern lenses for a minute and try to
see the world through their lenses
that's the only way to study history
it's the only way to see history and
understand it and if we're going to do
that if we're going to see things in
perspective in a historical context then
I think we have to afford that same
generosity to the Confederates which
isn't to say that we have to see slavery
as okay again it wasn't it's objectively
wrong and even you know in in
1860 you know in the year 1400 everyone
thought slavery was okay in 1860 there
were a lot of people who knew that was
wrong
so monistic on text doesn't let them off
the hook the same way that it would in
the year 1400 because we can say of a
person in 1860 yeah you should have
known better and they should have but
overall it was not as racially
enlightened at a time as it is today and
so that is a context that we have to
apply to everybody all right let's check
emails Matt wall show at gmail.com Matt
wall show at gmail.com let's see this is
from anonymous says dear supreme
dictator and Overlord Walsh relevant
backstory raised in a loving Catholic
home until I graduated high school early
to mid-20s fell away from the church
premarital sex drugs alcohol abuse all
through college currently still in
mid-20s
I've sobered sobered up routinely
participated in confession I attend
weekly Mass I am desperately working
towards renewing my faith prayer life
and stopping my Cavalier cafeteria
Catholic lifestyle in a steady exclusive
increasingly serious relationship with a
great girl but in my regrettable period
of debauchery before my girlfriend and I
were ever together I unknowingly had a
one-night stand with her sister during a
bullet bourbon blackout the sister and I
decided to never tell my girlfriend
about our indiscretion to avoid the
myriad of consequences although recently
a part of me wants to come clean so I
asked is the truth at all times despite
the consequences always the correct path
do I continue to live with my guilt
while pretending nothing happened at
every one of her family get-togethers
every date night every signed a piece of
mass to prevent her feelings of sadness
and betrayal do I break up with her to
save her the heartbreak even though I
don't want to break up with her this all
could have been avoided by better
choices I get it but any words of advice
moving forward would be helpful well
thanks for the email listen I think
you're right to realize that we need to
exercise prudence in deciding what to
share with people even with those whom
in a relationship it's not necessarily
the right move to just vomit out all of
your deepest darkest secrets and air all
of your dirty laundry so you're right
about that but in this case I think you
need to tell your girlfriend about this
she needs to know and I'll tell you why
at this point it's it's not really about
what you did before you were with her
now it's about this secret that you're
keeping with her sister there's another
woman and which you have apparently
communicated with her sister about you
said you both made a decision not to
tell her so clearly you've talked about
this the two of you and that's the
problem I think the problem it's not
that you have a past it isn't that you
made bad decisions when you were younger
we all have a past a lot of us made bad
decisions and and that's that's okay
you're moving past it you're changing
you're confronting it you're dealing
with it and that that's all great but
this isn't about the past it's about
right now and right now you're keeping a
secret with another woman and that woman
happens to be your girlfriend sister
even if it wasn't I mean even if she was
just some other random girl the fact
that you're keeping a secret with a
woman is a problem because a secret is
intimacy there is intimacy in keeping a
secret with someone and that's why when
you're in a serious relationship you
simply cannot have secrets with other
women I mean you you can't confide in
members of the opposite sex when you're
in a relationship keep secrets with them
and that sort of thing the fact that
she's the sister just makes it even more
the case so I would tell her I think you
should just tell her and explain it as
you explained it to me just now I can
pretty much guarantee that her main bone
of contention with you will be the
secret that you guys kept it's not gonna
be what you did the first thing she's
gonna be upset about is the secret I
don't know how long you've kept it but
that's gonna be the thing she's upset
about first and foremost but the longer
you keep the secret the more hurtful it
will be so I would just tell her and if
you're
relationship is meant to be if it's
strong if it's if it's made of the stuff
that lasts then it will survive this
it's gonna be difficult I mean there's
you know you guys are gonna have a tough
time I think probably for a bit but and
if it if and I know it's it's difficult
to think in these terms but if it
destroys the relationship and if all
falls apart then that probably means
that it just wasn't meant to be but
better to find that out now you know
better for you and for your girlfriend
all right this is from from Barth says
hi mr. walsh i'm a freshman at a
Catholic school I'm a huge fan of your
show I agree with you so much of the
time that I have not felt the need to
email but when you came after the office
you came it you came after me you said
that the office peaked around season
four this is completely untrue the best
string of episodes from the office is at
the very end of the series with the
Florida episodes until the episode where
Andy returns from his trip to the
Caribbean
I will now join the resistance to your
theocratic dictatorship instead of a
submissive serf well Barth the life
expectancy of a submissive Sert's serf
under my regime is quite a bit longer
than the life expectancy of a member of
the resistance but you know you do what
you think is best
as for the office yeah I was talking
about this on Twitter yesterday I you
know the office stopped being funny in
season five I mean season four is when
the drop off happened seasons 1 through
3 are the classics and as I explained
you know here's what happened with the
office and this is what happens with
with every comedy that sticks around too
long it had one South Park I mean it
happens with that with every comedy with
all great comedies you know and that's
why I think every comedy should end like
you really four or five seasons is
probably enough to tell the story and to
wring everything you can out of the main
joke and then at that point you got to
end it and what happened with the office
is that it started and what made it
great and relatable and funny and and
you know all those things and charming
was that it was a these were a
collection of basically normal people
who had this weird awkward boss
and this other you know his his dorky
sidekick and they were just kind of
existing and getting getting through the
day you know dealing with the dynamics
of the office and that's what made it
funny is that it was it was normal it
was real you could kind of imagine
meeting all these people in real life
that kind of reminded you of people that
you knew but as time went on and the
writers ran out of material and they
couldn't figure out how to generate
comedy anymore out of these mundane
situations they just turned everybody in
the office into a cartoon and pretty you
know pretty soon around season five is
when the switch happened where everybody
in the office was absurd and stupid and
ridiculous and and and not human at all
and when that happens it's just not
funny anymore
all right we'll do one more let's see
says from Dave says in school my
religion teacher preaches Dorothy
Saleh's don't know if I'm pronouncing
that right interpretation of God as a
supernatural but not omnipotent entity
which because if God in her opinion was
omnipotent he would be a cruel God since
he let the holocaust happen this is sort
of simplified because soul a of course
goes way deeper into the issue can you
explain how to argue for an omnipotent
God to that sort of Christian well if
we're dealing with someone who already
believes in God then I think it's pretty
easy to argue for omnipotence because
all we have to do is establish what his
bare minimum abilities would need to be
in order for him to be a God in the
first place right as far as that goes if
he didn't create the world if he is not
the creative force behind the world then
he is just a created being himself which
means he's not God he at that point he's
just a more powerful version of a human
being he's like he's maybe like a very
advanced alien or something like that
so God to be God would need to be first
he would need to be the first being not
a created being and therefore he's the
first being then he is the creative
force which created everything else and
that brings up the question you
is it possible for a non omnipotent
being to exist from all eternity and
then at some point decide to create out
of nothing 100 billion galaxies can a
non omnipotent being create even a blade
of grass let alone a hundred billion
galaxies that's the question and I would
say no because creating something out of
nothing is the ultimate power all other
powers that you can think of involve
manipulating things that already exist
in our environment but to create from
nothing you know to just have
nothingness and in that nothingness to
to make something appear doesn't matter
what that thing is well that is the
hallmark of unlimited power of
omnipotence
and so that's why God is omnipotent I
guess
maybe another way of framing it is if
God is powerful enough to create the
universe from nothing what do you think
he can't do so if she's saying that God
isn't omnipotent then then he/she must
have some things in mind that she thinks
he can't do well what would those things
be what would those you know can you
list some things that would be out of
the reach of a of a God who can who can
create a universe from nothing I can't
so that just that doesn't work that that
seems to me to be a kind of a cheap and
silly way of getting around the problem
of evil and all of that and that is a
complex problem it's a difficult problem
why why doesn't why didn't God stop the
Holocaust why doesn't God why does God
allow bad things to happen so on and so
forth and that is a whole separate
question we've talked about it before we
could talk about it for five hours right
but I certainly know that trying to
dethrone God essentially to take away
his power is not the way to deal with
that question because at that point
you're only a step away from atheism
if you're going to say well the
Holocaust happened because God couldn't
stop it
then I mean why not just say the
Holocaust happen because there is no God
it seems like that you're kind of
marching in that direction alright we'll
leave it there thanks for watching
everybody thanks for listening Godspeed
hi everyone I'm Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show well Jill Biden
is right about one thing we are in a
battle for the soul of America it's a
battle between one vision where the deep
state runs everything and another where
we run it let's talk about it on the
Andrew Clavin show I'm Andrew Clavin